peu à peu
[Musique]
bon la quarante huitième fois le peuple
russe était dans la rue conviés à venir
admirer sa puissance un matin glacial de
première une fois de plus ils venaient
contempler ces merveilleuses machines
ces engins prodigieux en un mot ces
fusées le choix de ce pays tout entier
tourné vers l'industrie lourde ne veut
plus d'autres symboles et passe
rapidement sur les chars et les canaux
seul maintenant ce qui part dans
l'espace est capable de déclencher
l'enthousiasmé chez les hommes on peut
voir dans ces armes les garants de la
paix la manifestation d'une agressivité
contrôler ou la légitime défense
en réalité pour le moment le peuple
soviétique combler d'orgueil pense qu'il
va arrivé le premier sur la lune
[Musique]
et
et comme son rival américain y pense
beaucoup
mais l'esprit est un peu différent est
ce parce que l'effort qui lui est
demandée prêts personnels et se traduit
par des difficultés quotidiennes et non
par un sacrifice d'argent est ce parce
que tous ici se rappelle que tout cela
est devenu possible en très peu de temps
et grâce à chacun d'eux toujours est il
que ce peuple imaginatif donne à la
conquête de l'espace un caractère qui
lui est propre
ce n'est pas par hasard c'est l'auteur
le plus cité par les savons que nous
avons rencontrés et jules verne
[Musique]
nous n'avons vu de l'astronautique
soviétique que deux cosmonautes charmant
et des séquences filmées à part cela
tout est secret les laboratoires les
usines les bureaux et le mystérieux
beitenou avait survécu
alors en attendant l'on vous conseille à
moscou d'aller voir le pavillon du
cosmos de l'exposition visite hautement
instructive
le cosmos c'est le ventre bien astiqués
de lune à neuf les vostok brûler les
dessins de stations dans l'espace
toutes ces techniques même celle de
science fiction semble classique mais
les songes russe redonne vie et
signification à ses morceaux de métal
mars vénus c'est la connaissance c'est
intéressant mais la lune
c'est un vieux rêve d'abondance à peine
transformé la lune c'est l'âge d'or
celle aventure mêlée au plaisir
d'utiliser l'univers de le posséder pour
en profiter ces adolescents qui encercle
joyeusement qu'amar'e fait léonov venu
avec nous au pavillon du cosmos ont été
élevés dans le respect la familiarité de
la chose scientifique qui matérialise
leurs efforts peut-être tout doucement
deviennent-ils plus avides de
satisfaction immédiate
peut-être que quelque chose est en train
de changer en urss la science de
l'espace à tort voix raison qu'on le
veuille ou non est encore du domaine de
l'idéalisme et la foule garde intactes
pour d'autres les sentiments de ferveur
et privés pour la gamme de produits
tous les enfants d'union soviétique
savent mettre un nom sur ce visage celui
de tchaïkovski un obscur professeur de
moscou qui imagina dessina calcula dès
la fin du siècle dernier les astronef
propulsées par fusée capable d'emmener
des hommes à la conquête des planètes
[Musique]
ce n'est peut-être pas par hasard que le
premier spoutnik lança c'est bip bip
autour de la terre en octobre 1957 au
moment où l'on fêtait en urss le
centième anniversaire de la naissance de
tchaïkovski considéré là bas comme le
créateur le l'astronautique mondiale il
faut des héros peuple russe et les
cosmonautes héros de la science sont les
porte drapeaux qui illustre la volonté
du pays d'être partout le premier sur le
chemin du progrès que le mystère soit
entier le secret rigoureux autour des
projets des relations spatiales ne
trouble pas les soviétiques
personne ne sait quel est le prix payé
ni combien d'hommes travaillent pour la
conquête de l'espace
parfois les soviétiques voix sur leur
téléviseur
des images comme celles ci qui nous
montre en tout cas que les techniques
d'entraînement des cosmonautes russes
sont à peu près les mêmes que celles de
leurs confrères américains
[Musique]
oh
je
et
[Musique]
dans le domaine spatial aux rencontres
pourtant la bonhomie l'absence de souci
esthétique la décontraction souriante
qui caractérise presque tous les centres
de recherche en urss avec aussi une
poésie naturel titoff à l'entraînement
récite des poème de pouchkine pour
tromper l'ennui d'un séjour fastidieux
dans une chambre d'isolement
[Musique]
les bouchons ont atteint quatre jours
après batman casnos munich moscou span
yens nikon va aid poupe kevin équipes
uci world skies maillet yanni richard
kimble hier matin des familles il est
rose l'albanie est ainsi formé hier ni
cannibale apprécié
[Musique]
m
popovic lui préférant donner le temps du
muguet dans l'autocar qu'il le mène vers
sa fusée
[Musique]
personne n'en doute en urss traite un
soviétique qui le premier mettra le pied
sur la lune quand bientôt comment
personne ne le sait mais chacun est
convaincu que les hommes de science qui
préparent le grand voyage le mèneront à
bonne fin
[Musique]
chez les enfants l'enthousiaste pour
l'espace se traduit comme on le voit
souvent en urss par une application
discipline et un effort mené avec un
très grand sérieux
[Musique]
nous sommes dans la section des
apprentis cosmonaute
le club des pionniers de moscou qui
groupe des adolescents de 12 à 16 ans
garçons et filles viennent ici plusieurs
fois par semaine discipliner leurs noces
pour vaincre l'appréhension le vertige
l'étourdissement sur les mêmes machines
qu utilisent réellement les cauchemars
[Musique]
ils savent bien qu'ils ne seront pas
tous des gagarine ou des valentina
terechkova mais tous en rêvent
[Musique]